[Music] Yeah can aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa [
Music
Hey, you're
probably hungry, right? I'll get ready right away, so let's have breakfast. At
dawn, he checks the area around the 6-tatami mat for footprints.
Goblins move around at night, but
when morning comes, they'll be back to normal, but before running.
He said that he always scouts the area and investigates the
footprints.Even if there are no footprints, he carefully inspects the work to make sure there are no loose or damaged parts.If
there are any broken parts, they can be repaired.  I took the crossbars to the pile and
repaired them.His
days have not changed since I came here five years ago.